vous avez nommé plusieurs femmes
plusieurs politicienne lors de votre
discours hier vous êtes également la
première femme noire à la tête de partis
et fédérales au canada est-ce que ça
c'est important pour vous oui absolument
la représentation diverses est très
important c'est une de nos forces au
canada mais malheureusement à des
personnes à provenant des groupes
minoritaires ne sont pas très bien
représenté dans notre vie politique
ah c'est très important comme un symbole
c'est très important pour des raisons at
a quitté à mais aussi parce que sans
cette représentation divine ou de crayon
des politiques avec des énormes lacunes
avec adp qui manque à des perspectives
importantes
alors oui absolument c'est très très
important je suis attrapés pour beaucoup
les canadiens est très fier de nos
membres d'avoir a choisi d'élire à mme
nash est comme moi madame paule vous
êtes avocate en droit international
vous remplacez donc qu'il est bête mais
qui était à la tête du parti vert depuis
les 13 dernières années qu est ce que
vous vous pensez à apporter au parti
vert
j'espère d'apporter votre les
perspectives d'une à différents a vécu
j'ai passé plusieurs années à l'étranger
a travaillé dans les affaires
internationales
je suis je suis je proviens de notre
parti de notre pays
ajout être voit fort pour novembre
je veux apporter d'énergie je veux âme
je veux rassembler des nouveaux membres
pour l'autre partie parce que c'est un
moment très très important pour le parti
vert a c'est nous qui avons proposé des
politiques les plus importants a en ce
moment un de revenu minimum garanti à
l'assurance à médicament universel à et
je crois que les canadiens il constate
en ce moment que nous sommes prêtes à
gouverner nous sommes une semble parti
avec des idées alors c'est pas moi de
communiquer
ce message très drôle très logiquement à
mais on a vu quand même l'année passée
vous souvenez certainement l'un des
millions de personnes dans les rues de
montréal et donc les causes vers les
causes environnementales touchait les
gens mais ça ne s'est pas traduit un
vote en élection des députés pour le
parti vert ou presque port on sait que
les gens ont décidé à plus qu'un tiers à
des dégâts des électeurs horizon a
choisi voter stratégiquement en fait ils
ont voté contre
quelque chose est pas pour quelque chose
alors tout a changé
nous sommes en train de nom nous sommes
dans le milieu la dune à d'une crise
urgente dans une pandémie âmes et nous
avons noté que nous avons des énormes
lacunes dans notre île et social par
exemple a je crois que les gens mais non
ils ont décidé que il ya des choses plus
important que de voter stratégiquement à
ils ont ils sont prêts pour une autre
option une option qui de place à une
première à au premier rang à et c'est
comme ça que les partis verts autour
demande normalement y fait leurs grands
après alors en quelques secondes mahdavi
paul va de la priorité pour votre début
de mandat comme chef en priorité c'est
de communiquer avec les canadiens s'ils
cherchent une option qui va lutter
contre la crise climatique et aussi a
finalement complété notre avis les
social c'est le parti vert nous sommes
le maître de la maison pour tous les
progressistes au canada un ami paul chef
du parti vert élu hier soir merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous et
félicitations merci beaucoup